this year those nominated for Best  Performance by an actor are well a mouth  fell in the sunshine boys Jack Nicholson  in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest  Al Pacino on Dog Day Afternoon  maximilian schell and the man of the  glass booth  james whitmore and given pal Harry  and then went away Jack Nicholson  well I guess this proves there as many  nuts and the Academy as anywhere else  but since you gave me the chance I'm  really happy to get an opportunity to  thank Saul and Michael and Louise and  Brad and Lawrence and Bo and all of the  guys in the company all of the feebs  brigade and i'd like to thank mr.  Pickford who incidentally I believe was  the first actor to get a percentage of  her pictures  and speaking of a percentage last but  not least my agent - about 10 years ago  advised me that I had no business being  an actor thank you